tu te souviens comment tu te souviens comment
Alice n'était pas toujours au pays des merveilles elle
est tombée au fond d'un trou pourquoi je
n'étais pas toujours dans la chambre je suis comme Alice
j'étais une petite fille nommée joie ouais et je
vivais dans un  maison avec ma mère et mon père
tu les appellerais grand-mère et grand-père
quelle maison maison c'était dans le monde et
il y avait une arrière-cour nous avions un hamac nous
nous balancions dans le hamac et nous mangions
de la glace
Keeney house no Jack une vraie maison pas la télé
est-ce que tu m'écoutais même quand j'étais
un peu plus vieux quand j'avais 17 ans je
rentrais de l'école à pied je tu étais
toujours au paradis mais il y avait un gars
il prétendait que son chien était un gars vieux
Nick nous l'appelons vieux Nick je  Je ne sais pas
quel est son vrai nom, mais il a prétendu que
son chien était un chien nommé Jack.
histoire que vous obtenez il
m'a mis dans son abri de jardin ici la chambre est l'
abri bien c'est des déchets je vais vous chercher du neuf
ceux pour les friandises du dimanche il y aura tellement
de friandises et pas seulement le dimanche bien
où est le bain il y a une douche c'est
noir ici
marteau
-piqueur ma volonté il nous trouve non tu ne nous trouveras jamais
parfois ça me manque ce n'était pas ça
sentait terriblement ça allait tous
direction jusqu'à la fin ça n'a jamais fini le
centre commercial était toujours là mais c'était plus petit
hmm qu'as-tu fait dans le sommeil de la garde-robe
quand le vieux Nick est venu je sais qu'elle a dit qu'elle avait
juste besoin d'être allons voir
Jack rencontrer Seamus habituellement pour le caresser